oh I've made merry oh [ __ ] we're going
for it ah we're gonna dive bomb it oh
[ __ ] it now he's got it
no does Oh so graceful - turn it - gosh
I am when take that Trump I mean
literally take that please take it carry
it with you and maybe stab Sant are
behind this is literally in pot there's
the lid there's no there's no way oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna or my grundle area is and
then it's gonna it's a different rope
swing oh oh it's so pretty
no please old man help me you magical
flying Beast please swing swung my body
I'll give you my arm it's tasty and
delicious don't know why I'm assuming
you're a cannibal but maybe not if this
stupid ah [ __ ]
husky [ __ ] Wow well ain't this a
predicament oh gosh oh well can't wait
to tell the guys at the bar
about this ah there we go ha I got it
yay ah come on
ah there we go we got it we got it we
got it we're good we're good don't mind
me just doing the splits over here can
you grab can you grab us alright hey but
WWE move contests I [ __ ] I call this one
the inverted none can I hit you please I
call this one the undulating beaver hi
smooch on the top of your head oh it's
such a tender romantic moment now if you
wouldn't mind just sucking something for
me I want to call this one the the
cheese I'm gonna call this one the
unsure about my feelings I'm gonna go
this way this is a bad idea okay I'm
gonna try this one more time except less
stupid well thank me well now I have
this with me forever and ever come on
get over all cheese it's causing a bit
of a problem it's screwing up my
aerodynamics get it [ __ ] you gonna make
it oh person run broad run go for it I'm
flying
[Music]
oh okay boss Oh son we're going on a
vacation
okay have a good day at school if I
could just collect all these harpoons
inside my a nose rope swing impossible -
what's that Oh impossible you see ow
impossible you say imperfect I just have
to play this one again because it's like
the world's most violent prostate exam
[Music]
all right son you stay there I'm gonna
get my weirdly magical legs
okay lost an arm - but it's still
dangling by a weird attachment but okay
apparently mr. a K you're gonna come
with me because we've got some business
to sort out I need to speak with your
manager could you please try to kick you
off but you excuse me you're being very
rude
this whole establishment I need my
brains inside my head did you shoot at
me I can't remember I'm very drunk and
also I was recently stitched together
you seem to be specifically aiming for
my leg and it's somehow still trying to
pump well now my arm is gone at least if
I got one leg I still got hope Wow all
right we're gonna we're gonna get this I
just need to stop losing so many wood
all right just stop being a dick stop it
stop it stop how about you shut up [ __ ]
oh what's that you missed me and hit
don't know what happened there everyone
fell down then I died that makes you
extra stupid well both legs gone Mike
still go and get a billy get him got a
Billy Billy missed the mortar met the
purchase okay don't have arms but when
have I ever needed arms before okay we
made it right sniper
hey I got all my limbs hey I'm okay oh
this is going wonderful today also I
seem to be going faster for some bizarre
reason I thought my brain was going to
blow but it turns I'm just dead anyway
alright we're gonna get some speed now
please enjoy this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye